hey how's it going for us - but today
we're playing Morphy a game but morphing
it's already the greatest game I ever
played and I can't wait to play more ooh
Oh with this stock via shake I love it
make me wanna dance here we go
this is me semi my posture is not the
best that's okay I can mean Drive with
obvious that's awesome
I can piss best game best game Jess I
don't get to see my dick though
do I even have wood that's the real
horror of this game how long am I gonna
piss Jesus Christ [ __ ] out I did not
ah what kind of [ __ ] piss then [ __ ] me
Peter you're a loser talking yeah
awesome I broke the game man this shadow
is hot [ __ ] again [ __ ] ass let's see
if we can exit without breaking the game
now ah it did it work okay we did it
that [ __ ] is this is creepy oh god are
those my shoes awesome
oh wow oh wow we will you are a walking
airplane everyone knows planes don't
walk silly plane
the [ __ ] is talking like that all right
guys man I got a bad you got a bad drug
experience right now this night I don't
I don't like this hello
let me go stop whispering Jesus [ __ ]
ass okay let's go upstairs battle no
probably not
oh there's an invisible ghost layer that
I prevents me from okay let's just go
down the corridor 420 nice nice one mate
okay that's not creepy it's this weird
I want you for rabbits rabbits I hate
them awesome
this is the best game why can I not go
down the [ __ ] stairs
[ __ ] you rabbits
alright what's with the walking plane
like a metaphor or something alright
what do we got
I don't know how to exit out of this
screen
they keep whispering and the editors
name is Martin Felix that's a that's an
awesome name [ __ ] hell mate what is
this okay okay
honestly like being on morphine would
help be a lot more fun in this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] okay so remember not to
click on that one because if you do the
game breaks awesome hey dude sup can I
go down now can I go down now no there's
people awesome [ __ ] ghost people man
all right what do we got another note
awesome I love alumnos oh this is creepy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] kit y'all the bunny hey oh [ __ ]
Jesus ass licking [ __ ] that's actually
kind of creepy what the hell oh oh
you're laughing now
what a dick I don't like this game this
keeps stupid game oh no it's still of
course there's a how you doing buddy get
the [ __ ] whispering I got an
achievement for sharing at the rabbit I
go down I can't go down ladies and
gentlemen there is hope
I'm Mort Mort okay awesome note my
favorite notes so far what the [ __ ] is
this
we're name and get these tools [ __ ] you
sis Jesus Christ us that's awesome did
it amazing
all right well so far so good that
[ __ ] bunny man I found a hidden
rabbit so I got it I got a achievement
that's awesome
I need to find a way to open well I
don't [ __ ] know
the bucket is useless apparently I could
just go over
this game is so bizarre everything is
useless how am I supposed to see ah this
is [ __ ]
okay well I got some [ __ ] horseshoes
so yeah that that I did that I did that
oh no I'm out of battery so I can't walk
anymore hmm
awesome oh it is stable that's sleeping
horse goddammit
okay I need tools now [ __ ] hell man
what happened oh this is gameplay look
at this ten out of ten this game just
hey we did all that just take just a ah
I just hey awesome [ __ ] awesome hmm
oh we can do that again huh huh oh there
we go
awesome just hey all that for just hey
just just just some good ol hey what
about you that one needs a key hmm well
let's go in here huh hey buddy how you
doing Betty oh whoa smack that ass hey
how you doing buddy wake the [ __ ] up
come on horsey wake up
you lazy son of a [ __ ] studies unicorn
orange sticking out of his ass awesome
that's great can I hate stuff now
Babbitt at bap bap bap at up better put
it back put up a pepper there but it
lets try take this Hank
let's ride you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] snakes inside a Jesus
Christ all right well let's keep
searching the hey bruh there must be the
same and now say last one empty [ __ ]
out where I where is it then man gonna
be this hey all right well this hay is
indestructible for some reason it's
overly ambitious and it's not finished
look at this the [ __ ] horseshoe
[ __ ] [ __ ]
look at that blurriness like just hey
just hey just hey just say hey will you
say hey just hey Marvin Doris
like a robot think my hand is stuck in
the door
just hey hey hey just just just just Hey
I've seen my father hiding the Spanky in
the barn now the [ __ ] is useful this is
fun hello little friends you're free
yes begone live your life fulfill your
dreams become a lawyer
I don't know III empty what the [ __ ]
horsey or say what is your secret
for sake you lazy son of a [ __ ]
I hate you horse he used to be such a
good friend of mine used to be my
wingman it always get me laid and if not
I would get laid with him sure sorry
where the [ __ ] [ __ ] up
why is everything empty nice damage ah
yeah oh god it almost crashed I thought
all right here we go unlock that [ __ ]
yeah yeah I'm free what I okay there
must be something here some tool
something give me something damn it
what are you nicely placer [ __ ] hell
you're ugly you got some nice face there
bro but a man cannot compliment another
maize tanks [ __ ] you oh my god how long
are you gonna live [ __ ] hell
what do you want I need to get out I
need to get it what a dick hey all right
god this shoehorn again huh you want me
what a dick hit this again oh that was
fun
I am the lock-picking bastard best game
best game 2016 12 2017 9 yes some planks
that I can clearly walk over well [ __ ]
me then looks like I could not care less
about the [ __ ] story
adverse fear the gameís atmosphere I'll
give you that right
and some scares but like [ __ ] hell
fire cabinet we're back in school it
seems and we're following the green
light of green lightness hello there
another [ __ ] them alright I get it
you're a [ __ ] loser it's getting old
mate it's the worst trip I ever had like
I did not ask for [ __ ] GU people what
is this Power Rangers what are you doing
eating go and [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] all of you oh alright what a bit
that is you're not goo you guys aren't
good what the [ __ ] why are they speaking
with our minds what the [ __ ] is this hi
guys excuse me I'm just gonna press that
oh my food is here oh it looks delicious
wow the school food is isn't the food
the best isn't it okay alright I love
food hey how you how you guys soon you
like food nice scarf bro yeah it works
well free can I say here alright today
am must yes empty table just for me yeah
pdop I love sitting by myself everyone
else is so boring oh girl I'm sorry I
wanted to be alone can you [ __ ] off
please please no no skipping alright
that's cool I don't know why but this
game is actually entertaining it's so
[ __ ] and you [ __ ] off hey bro what's up
bro
what a dick eating like let's [ __ ]
punish someone like that yeah super mean
you're super super duper mean man uncool
okay then
alright [ __ ] you no okay no all right
Martin I don't know what what you even
say anymore I am out of say Ness ace
what you say that you only meant well
well of course you dude
okay now we're at third-person awesome
no not anymore it was just during the
cutscene ah
oh yeah I can still move ah
no hi guys
go to your tent loser man which I don't
need I don't even know which tent was
mine like if I know which tent was mine
I'd go oh of course this is my tent
lonely I need to make a fire apparently
all right well I can I can do that oh
why was I invited out here no one likes
me click the fort where is the stone Zen
like what
fluke some nice ok I'm swinging Oh
awesome best game best game Oscar Oscar
I am DB 10 out of 10 8 over 9 I got into
much for riding for 15 seconds I am
really [ __ ] at the swing or night but
that doesn't stop me they may be
bullying me they may think I'm a loser
but when I ride that swing oh man I ride
it so high I'm gonna pierce I'm going to
pierce the heavens I'm gonna pierce the
heavens with this swing the moon we're
gonna drill through the moon with this
swing nothing's gonna stop my swing
nothing nothing's gonna stop me from
doing this I don't care if people make
fun of me I don't care what you say
about me I'll ride my swing damn it I
write it all that all if I a cow
ah I'm gonna jump up I'm gonna jump off
are you ready Terry Cobbs oh that's it
that's it
best game ten out of eight all right
let's go over here first game
alright creepy better better go back
wait where's this is it up okay yeah no
no I remember that I remember that from
the other game secret I'm a wizard I'm a
wizard I can go I'm Harry Potter I'm
[ __ ] everybody look at this
oh the [ __ ] are you doing
I have a full unit i Fox take me to the
sounds get it cuz I'm a STONER haha
because the game was morphine haha
alright come on
ain't got own [ __ ] name in token am
what it goes back now what the [ __ ] oh
my god just take me to the stones what
the [ __ ] are you doing
where's the [ __ ] stones can clearly
see the edge of the map
awesome awesome just awesome awesome no
this is gameplay right oh I got a stone
look at Jennifer I wanna friend let the
play take me to the fair yes Jennifer I
will take you home and make sweet sweet
love - yeah there we go
but I have a still here sure you missed
it shut up
shut your [ __ ] [ __ ] mouth and stab
it Jesus Christ what'd I say huh I need
to find more stones you're replaceable
be
all right know your [ __ ] plate one
more ok well I'm finding a lot of stones
here I'll pick some more putting the
ones in my hand what the [ __ ] in my own
about what kind of drugs am I on stupid
question I guess Jesus Christ alright
more stones more soda Stan alright
alright alright alright alright alright
alright one more there we go I will find
some bushes why am I doing this how do
you find a bush how how you're a bush
there's there's there's bushes
everywhere
what kind of bush in particular am I
looking for hmmm this is a bush in it no
all right what about [ __ ] you swing what
the [ __ ] is a bush what the [ __ ] is a
bush what the [ __ ] is a bush what the
[ __ ] is a birch there's clearly no
purchase could this be a bush no it's
not a bush what about this purse it's
not a bush let's push it over there but
I'm too scared
where's my where's my bouche where's my
boo boo boo Sh my boo my booty push with
a focus push push man come on come on
push show yourself
what is it I don't understand I just I
just don't understand what do you want
me to do where did you find the bush
[ __ ] you swing yeah
Bush yeah that was clearly a birch how
could I not see that Bush man oh man oh
good man way I could I don't see that
push man push once you find them all got
a Farnam all pushing on gosh I want a
fire baby of it guys guys I'm fighting
so many [ __ ] bushes [ __ ] you do that
alright few more bushes and I've out of
that should do it
gotta find them Oh
one more one more bus brah blah blah one
more version and we're done this is the
most fun I ever had playing a video game
like honestly hundred percent serious
every time I play a horror game
I just think hey I might man I would
really wish the horror would just stop
so I could find some [ __ ] bushes and
in in the darkness oh my god oh he
thinks that's enough that's that's funny
that's comedy
[ __ ] you swing I'm not gonna swing you
anymore
alright take the marshmallows from my
bag all right there little yeah alright
alright
now now we can make marshmallows we're
doing with a there it is okay awesome
press F to cook press F to feel sad
press F to feel lonely cuz everyone is
over there I slowly put my marshmallows
closer to the flames and slowly I become
more lonely miss this guy clearly don't
even know how to cook marshmallows no
wonder anyone want to sit with him may
you gotta spin them around I can't with
this guy
kinda listen to some music before I go
ah
so now it's good to be lonely I don't
one day I have my election Ted my only
wish is to get rid of Ted
all right that was game playing that was
so
why do I keep running out of battery
[ __ ] hell awesome Luke Swamp frog
swamp at the FIFA by god yay
heads rad me shut up I'm not gonna ride
you or anyone except Jane where is that
[ __ ] I have to find Jane I'm sure she
didn't go that way
okay well what about this way then oh it
was it was it was it was that way Oh
awesome so scared best game best game
best game paid money for this game
J
Jay said Jay sad Jay said Jane O'Shea
was Jane you're right
Milky Way is pretty it's funny I was
raining even though the sky is clear
that's that's pretty awesome gameplay
right there oh the tree fella can't walk
there sorry
like I don't know how train works but
awesome let's go in here hi hi hi hi
there
the [ __ ] just happened I want this Latin
hello hello let's take a [ __ ]
well you can't piss anymore with the fun
this game was so good a second ago
someone is [ __ ] bats in the distance
oh this again now it is happening
oh hey you this game was so bad like you
can scare me all you want okay we're
gonna end it there all right best game
ever leave a thumbs up and I will never
play it again Thank You boys and Edgar
will do a breakfast now he's like oh I
don't wanna go cute come on grandpa oh
god [ __ ] okay we have grandpa's teeth I
didn't know we needed them better
apparently we did let's check out the
television